[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
c'est ça vous regarde en direct au
sommaire ce soir la crise sanitaire
relance la guerre entre paris et
marseille les annonces d'olivier véran
hier soir on était vécu comme un coup de
massue les élus sont en colère marseille
va t-elle se rebeller certains élus ont
même déposé un recours en justice dans
d'autres villes les mesures drastiques
ce commence à mal passé va-t-on les
faire accepter et comment c'est la
question du grand débat ce soir on
parlera aussi du projet de loi sur la
recherche censé mettre la france sur les
rails de la compétition internationale
25 milliards d'euros investis sur dix
dans cet inédit pour le gouvernement une
réforme en trompe l'oeil pour les
chercheurs face à face à suivre sur ce
plateau et tous ces sujets on va les
aborder avec un philosophe ce soir un
philosophe qui n'hésite pas à mettre les
pieds dans le plat pour lui la coved 19
ça n'est pas un si grave problème il y à
plus grave et nous perdons un peu en ce
moment la raison
andré comte sponville et notre grand
témoin ce soir voilà donc pour le
programme c'est parti au stade cvr pour
agir sur twitter tout de suite le grand
départ
[Musique]
bienvenue à tous - de sports - de
rassemblement et plus du tout de bars et
de restaurants c'est donc le nouveau
régime sec qui attend les marseillais à
partir de samedi prochain marseille et
elle punie comme le disent ses élus
va-t-on vers un divorce entre les
territoires et l'état bonsoir anne
genetet soit merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes député la république en marche des
français d'asie d'océanie et d'europe de
l'est c'est vous qui suivez dans la
majorité cette crise sanitaire
depuis le début bonsoir george
pau-langevin lancement la députée
socialiste de paris paris qui dénoncent
par la voix d'anne hidalgo des mesures
trop restrictives
on y reviendra dans quelques minutes
bart martens blachier qui est médecin et
épidémiologiste va nous rejoindre et
bonsoir andré comte sponville bons soins
merci d'être avec nous c'est un plaisir
de vous accueillir dans ça vous regarde
vous êtes philosophe vous publiez ce
dictionnaire amoureux de montaigne aux
éditions plon montagne auquel vous avez
consacré toute votre vie
une grande part d'une bonne partie de ma
vie
vous y avez fait une très belle place
dans vos dans vos travaux
la crise que nous traversons cette crise
sanitaire
vous avez eu des propos qui ont pu un
peu bousculés on va y revenir en tout
cas on attend vos lumières sur ce que
nous vivons tous enfin bienvenu.merci ce
rallye parce que vous n'étiez pas avec
nous sur ce plateau maintenant j'ai une
promotion je suis directement avec vous
c'est vous exactement c'est vous qui
ouvrait le bal avec votre billet si j'ai
bien compris c'est tout de suite
[Musique]
si j'ai bien compris ce soir c'était si
j'ai bien compris
myriam marseille se rebelle contre la
capitale alors je veux dire en tant que
supporters du psg s'est vraiment pas le
truc qui est fait pour me donner parce
que là je pense que je suis bien placé
pour savoir qu'il existe quand même à
marseille un petit fond d'hostilité
contre les capitales mais on peut le
dire cette manière d'applaudir la
défaite de paris en finale de la ligue
des champions
ces explosions de joie dans tous les
bars bon ce n'est pas très fair play
reconnaissez le alors certes c'est du
folklore il est quand même bien vivant
on l'a vu récemment et du coup c'est
toujours un thème assez porteur à
marseille de jouer sur l'opposition au
contre la capitale d'ailleurs dès le
début de la crise du clavier on a vu que
marseille est un peu la tête de pont de
la contestation avec la personnalité du
professeur raoul
c'est donc depuis marseille que le
professeur raoul dénonçait les
technocrates parisiens hors sol nous en
posant bien sûr au bon sens des
scientifiques marseillais normal quoi
alors quels sont les élus aujourd'hui
ont repris un peu cette thématique les
reproches que font les marseillais les
élus à la capitale pas pour critiquer
les marseillais mais leurs reproches
n'ont rien d'original en fait ils font
les mêmes reproches à la capitale que
tout le reste des français c'est à dire
que trop de décisions sont prises à
paris sans concertation avec les élus
locaux vous montre un sondage du
parisien
pardon y compris les et du parisien les
elysées parisiens peuvent le penser
puisque anne hidalgo se plaint rfi donc
voyez mais le regarder le sondage café
le sénat récemment 75 % des français
sont pour que la décentralisation aille
plus loin donc moins de décisions prises
à paris c'est possible donc la
différence avec marseille sait qu'à
marseille on crie un peu plus fort
qu'ailleurs
d'ailleurs fin août fut pas si vous vous
souvenez les marseillais se sont
rassemblés donc avec le nouveau maire
ongles la nouvelle mère plutôt michel
rubio là à côté d'elle bleus protestera
ou mêmes l'adversaire de michel guiraud
la cire martine vassal élus et l'eire
qui elle aussi était sur la conférence
de presse
et le message était le même voilà ce que
disent des marseillais ils décident
depuis paris de ce qui serait bon pour
notre ville sans entamer le dialogue
nécessaire avec les élus et surtout sans
nous donner les moyens de faire
respecter les décisions qui sont les
leurs voilà depuis ce matin la mairie de
marseille réclament un délai de dix
jours pour cette fermeture des bars et
restaurants marseille va t elle être
entendu je n'en ai pas la moindre idée
donc jeu
vous répondra en revanche ce qui est sûr
c'est que les marseillais dans ce bras
de fer contre parise ont un sérieux
atout dans leur manche
sire que eux qui se plaignent que trop
de décisions se prennent à paris sans
concertation il ya quelqu'un qui est sur
la même longueur d'onde qu'eux et ça
peut compter dans le débat le président
de la république furie figurez-vous on
écoute j'en ai la conviction profonde
l'organisation de l'état et de notre
action doit profondément changer tout ne
peut pas être décidé si souvent à paris
tout ne peut pas être décidé à paris est
ce que olivier derand peut vraiment
décider à la place des marseillais que
va dire la gueule macron j'ai pas est ce
que vous croyez vraiment qu emmanuel
macron va faire confiance aux élus
marseillais
moi j'ai un petit doute un agent est
c'est pas la première fois qu'une
querelle entre entre paris et marseille
sauf que là les élus eelv ont déposé un
recours en justice le patron de la
région paca renaud muselier
c'est du folklore ce qui est en train de
se passer ou ça pourrait dégénérer
je dirais peut-être pas folklore non
plus je crois qu'on est dans une
difficulté que tout le monde peut
entendre
je pense que si quelqu'un avait la
réponse claire et évidente elle serait
depuis longtemps sur la table la
situation était extrêmement complexe on
est dans une situation très évolutive
toute décision que nous prenons
elle est le résultat de ce que nous
avons fait il ya quinze jours toute
décision que nous prenons maintenant
elle aura un effet dans quinze jours
donc c'est très compliqué et de devoirs
ce décalage dont j'entends tout à fait
là la difficulté et pas seulement à
marseille à un pari aussi donc ils l'ont
dit j'entends que ça puisse être très
survireuse table par un supporter mais
je voudrais rappeler un élément à porter
cette réflexion en corée en corée du sud
qui avait pas mal géré la situation
la reprise épidémique a eu lieu depuis
les bars et les milieux de la nuit
clairement donc on voit bien que ce sont
dans ces lieux où les gens se
rassemblent sont proches les uns des
autres ont du mal on peut le comprendre
à respecter la l'absence de contact
c'est compliqué c'est de là que ça
repart d'où l'extrême vigilance
on n'a pas envie de retrouver une
situation avec des hôpitaux saturés je
sais qu'à marseille en a déjà plus de
30% des lidd rien qu'ils sont occupés
par ça on n'a pas envie de voir nos
anciens n'ont plus vénérables mourir
c'est tout simplement de ça dont il
s'agit
on en a pas envie et on aimerait que
chacun arrive à se responsabiliser
je sais que c'est compliqué mais bon
sans tous ces gens qui adorent marchand
reçu la première
aller dans les bars dans les restos moi
je dois confesser que j'ai pas fait un
resto depuis trois mois j'attends
j'attends j'attends m'assurer que
vraiment je puisse reprendre
on va revenir sur sur la méthode parce
que ce n'est pas toujours simple de
suivre qui décide quoi localement ou
depuis paris george pau-langevin ce qui
fait qu'une moule marseille protégé il
ya un vrai problème de méthode dans ce
que ce qui se passe parce que d'une part
les élus locaux qui sont quand même en
première ligne ne sont pas suffisamment
concertée marseille râlent contre paris
mais paris elle même n'a pas été non
plus associé à la décision qui a été
prise et par ailleurs pour que le
citoyen lambda comprennent on peut pas
avoir en permanence au niveau des
changements de stratégie comme cela un
jour on rouvre on autorise les gens à
mettre des terrasses on permet aux gens
travailler c'était soyez volutes le
lendemain
bon on ferme donc je crois que il y a
sacré phénomène dans l'oise et là c'est
parti on a l'impression adaptabilité un
jour on fait comme ça certains chaumont
on a de l'avancé quand il n'ya pas de
suivi dans les décisions et dans le
respect des décisions
alors puisqu'on prévoit essaie quand
même de rester sur marseille à nathan
faut cliquer sur effectifs vont pouvoir
revenir largement sur la méthode
on vit une crise de l'incertitude andré
pons projet on tâtonne tout est évolutif
le productivisme noir jour était
incertaine est assurément une station
est complexe là dessus on est d'accord
je crois qu'il n'ya pas raisonnable
d'accabler les politiques qui font un
métier plus difficile que le vôtre ou le
mien quant au fond je pense que manuel
mâcon a raison il faut arrêter de tout
décider de paris votre citation était
piquante mais parfaitement pertinente
moi je le comprends un peu d'agacement
des marseillais et des parisiens à dire
pourquoi décider à paris de mesures de
protection sanitaire
d'autant rappelons le quand même que
cette épidémie de covin 19
ce n'est pas la fin du monde il y a un
fils je ne me lasse pas de répéter parce
que les journalistes ne le répète jamais
le taux de mortalité le taux de létalité
de lakovic 19 est situé par les experts
entre 0,3 et 0,5 pour cent ça veut dire
que si vous et moi nous attrapons
lakovic 19
avons en moyenne 99 dire que le 5 % de
chance d'en réchapper
moi je termine - peu moins parce que
j'ai 68 ans voue beaucoup plus que 99
cents de moins de 40 ans vous aurez le
temps de dire revenir largement vous
souhaitez surfer trêve c'est très
important c'est très importante et on
remettre les choses est un problème
sanitaire majeur mais arrêtons d'affoler
les gens comme si la mort était au coin
de la rue ce n'est pas vrai nom en
attendant est ce que les gens sont
affolés ou inquiets car mentalement des
bars et des restaurants voulez vous nous
dites fermer les bars et les restaurants
à marseille c'est une erreur non non je
dis il faut demander aux élus locaux
deux mois je suis cool à la
décentralisation mais au contraire de
vous chère madame je vais au restaurant
le plus souvent que je peux par
solidarité avec les excellents
restaurateurs qui travaille dans mon
quartier qui travaille énormément avec
du talent et qui ne savent pas si dans
six mois le restaurant valais on va les
écouter et jordana parole apparaît donc
un instant mais j'aimerais bien pour les
entendre c'est marseillais maintenant
ces bouches du rhône en zone rouge
écarlate
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont devoir subir
concrètement dans leur quotidien quels
sont les restrictions et comment ils
vivent tout ça c'est un récit signé
ahmed tasiast ici les annonces du
ministre de la santé font l'effet d'une
bombe
dès samedi sur tout le territoire de la
métropole
aix marseille les bars et les
restaurants devront fermer pour au moins
15 jours ce matin dans ce café à
marseille les clients ne comprennent pas
je suis allé hier faire mes courses à g
de surface alors soit on ferme tout est
vraiment ou s'occupent de notre saleté
mais de cibler les restaurateurs je
comprends pas
pourquoi bars les restaurants serait
plus dangereux
peu d'autres commerces ça n'a pas été ma
vie sociale j'ai envie de voir mes amis
j'aurais d'aller au restaurant dans les
terres tout ça ce sont les mesures les
plus strictes annoncé depuis confinement
un coup dur pour le gérant de cet
établissement
il a déjà perdu deux cent mille euros
depuis le début de l'année il va devoir
mettre neuf salariés au chômage partiel
on a fait des crédits pas que nous tous
les restaurateurs les commerçants ils
ont ce décret dit feu rembourser dans
moins de six mois ou les rendre
là on referme c'est pas ça fait peur ce
restaurateur lui va devoir s'organiser
dans sa chambre froide
près de 8000 euros de produits frais
comme on est sur du plat minutes
il ya beaucoup de marchandises comme
vous pourrez voir et de se séparer une
catastrophe économique pour ce
représentant de la profession en terme
d'image l'impact que ça va voir nous
allons avoir beaucoup moins de touristes
beaucoup moins de la destination est
beaucoup moins attractive et les élus
locaux prennent le relais conférence de
presse ce matin à la mairie de marseille
on ne décolère pas contre le
gouvernement une nouvelle fois notre
territoire est aujourd'hui sanctionner
unis montré du doigt alors vous
comprendrez que nous sommes aujourd'hui
dans l'incompréhension dans
l'incompréhension et dans la colère ici
des actions de contestation sont
annoncés reste à savoir qui de la cité
phocéenne où de paris cédera le premier
bonsoir martin lâché non seulement
mercier a d'être avec nous est médecin
et épidémiologiste et spécialiste des
questions de santé publique on l'entend
il est légitime son ras le bol des
marseillais
c'est très difficile et pour évidemment
les acteurs économiques mais mais pour
tous ceux qui vivent dans cette ville
elle était absolument nécessaire toutes
ces nouvelles mesures moi j'en suis pas
persuadé mais c'est très difficile
c'est très difficile de savoir ce qui
veut dire c'est que ces mesures sont
efficaces ça je peux dire que c'est pas
efficace est pas vrai et quand même
beaucoup maintenant il ya une étude
américaine et puis ya plein d'exemples
qui nous montrent que c'est efficace
après ce que c'était nécessaire j'en
suis pas certains pas tous d'accord et
j'ai mis les scientifiques j'en suis pas
certain qu'il ya des gens qui tracent
des traits c'est à dire que trace un
trait sur l'augmentation qui est celle
qui a eu la semaine dernière oui c'est
sûr que ça va augmenter mais normalement
il ya des mesures qui ont été prises
donc on attend quand même à ce que ça a
fléchi shalem ribeiro là la mère de
marseille elle dit que le taux
d'incidence donc le nombre de cas de
contamination pour 100000 habitants
étaient en train de baisser
et c'est pour ça qu'il ya aussi cette
voie je pression vous comprenez ça je
pense qu'un mouvement de panique la du
ministre de la santé et je pense que il
ose pas attendre dix jours et d'ailleurs
je crois que ce qui était proposé
moi je pense que si on attend 10 jours
ça infléchira je pense qu'il ya pas
besoin d'aller à cette étape là pour
l'instant
je pense que les mesures qu a annoncé la
semaine dernière et le port du masque
dans les lieux clos sans capacité de
contrôler cette reprise mouvement de
panique
il ya une semaine ils prennent des
mesures hélas une semaine après alors
qu'on peut pas observer c'est
mathématique l'émeut les résultats des
mesures qui ont été prises il ya une
semaine
il ferme les bars et les restaurants
donc moi je pense que c'est pas idiot
mais je pense que c'est trop tôt c'est
le timing est pas bon je pense
qu'effectivement s'ils attendent 10
jours ils n'auront pas besoin de faire
ça devenait compliqué à contretemps vous
allez trop vite vous paniquez je crois
en moi je sais pas moi qui paniquent
éventuellement le cas échéant ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que très
honnêtement on ferme
je comprends que certains soient
effectivement très mécontents mais
quelle que soit la décision il y aura de
toute façon des mécontents ou des
inquiets j'aimerais revenir sur ce qui a
été dit tout à l'heure et rappeler
qu'effectivement il faut pas oublier
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui s'en sort
très bien et non pas de complication la
seule chose qu'il faut bien conservés en
tête
le virus circule donc j'aurai juste
justifier pourquoi moi j'ai choisi nous
pas et dans les restaurants c'est dans
ma situation je pense que certains n'ont
pas tous le monde quelques françaises
dans ce cas là j'ai en charge des
parents âgés et malades à qui je n'ai
pas envie de transmettre notre coup je
prends mes précautions c'est ma
responsabilité
et ça serait c'est vrai formidable si
tout le monde pouvait en faire autant et
se dire là je vais dans un bar je me dis
prendrait 14 jours ou sept jours dont
qui suivent je prends des précautions
on aimerait en arriver à ce niveau de
responsabilité l'avant une communication
peut-être plus rassurante
je suis d'accord qu'elle est souvent
anxiogènes je le regrette
personnellement rester sur des choses
très simples effectivement on regarde
certaines courbes j'aime pas utiliser
des mots mais le virus circule
activement 1 2 on a des hospitalisations
qui augmente et trois des entrants
renier mes sentiments dans certains
territoires ne pas oublier que en région
marseille
ils n'ont pas du tout du tout été
pénalisée pendant la première vague donc
confusément des décisions c'est pas
absurde non plus dans l'observance
moment où on explique la flambée de
l'épidémie à marseille
est-ce que c'est uniquement parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de mouvements cet été ou est
ce que didier rahout lui même un certain
nombre de prises de position à une part
de rêve pour ça faisait longtemps qu'on
n'avait pas parlé non mais ce qu'il faut
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
les comportements de cet été déterminé
la reprise de la rentrée et d'ailleurs
si vous regardez les cours de bordeaux
et de marseille vous avez deux courses
sont complètement différentes marseille
sa montre
ça bordeaux ça montre comme ça et c'est
comme ça dans les différentes régions
donc c'est lié au comportement de cet
été une boîte c'est cet été qui aurait
fallu réagir pour éviter d'avoir cette
reprise le problème c'est que maintenant
on voit la vague hospitalière qui suit
la vague de circulation virale qu'on a
eu fin août et en fait on s'affole un
peu trop tard c'est à dire que là on va
trop loin par rapport à quelque chose
qui aurait pu être réglé en août et en
septembre donc en fait on a fait en été
on parle on est quasiment le seul pays
du monde n'a pas porter de masque l'été
moi je parlais tout à l'heure avec des
journalistes chinois il me regardait
comme ça estimé
vous avez une maladie respiratoire qui
se transmettent vous vous lavez les
mains mais vous portait pas de masque
l'été enfin il comprenait même pas que
c'est plus arriver donc en fait c'est ça
l'erreur qui fait qu'on a cette reprise
hivernale cet été à partir du tueur
c'était beaucoup répéter cet été le bas
ce n'était pas obligatoire
on raconte pendant comprenne bien je
vais au restaurant mes parents sont
morts depuis longtemps je comprends très
bien votre attitude mais je porte le
masque
je respecte les gestes barrière je n'ai
pas embrassé mes trois garçons depuis
plus de six mois
il se trouve que le restaurant on a le
droit d'égaler et mon attitude de
citoyens c'est d'utiliser au maximum les
libertés qu'on nous accorde encore parce
que je suis très content de voir des
médecins à la télévision tous les soins
mais la médecine est une grande chose il
n'y a pas que ça qui compte dans la vie
la liberté ça compte aussi l'économie ça
compte aussi mes parents sont morts nés
trois enfants y en a qui au chômage qui
cherchent du boulot depuis des mois les
six cent mille jeunes qui ont fini leurs
études en juin juillet qui rendent le
marché du travail
au pire moment vous croyez pas que c'est
plus grave que ma petite santé de quasi
septuagénaire
moi je me dis je fais je me fais plus de
soucis pour les jeunes que pour les gens
de ma génération côté a gâté par les
soirs quand le président m'a dit qu'on
disait au début du confinement
la priorité des priorités c'est de
protéger les plus vulnérables
il avait raison en situation de crise
sanitaire aiguë en mars ou avril
mais sur la durée on peut pas imaginer
un pays dont la priorité des priorités
pendant 40 ans sera le sort de ces
octogénaires
moi je dis ma priorité des priorités ce
sont les jeunes en général et les
enfants en particulier et les malheureux
gamins qui vont collège masques et huit
heures par jour qu'ils apprennent
l'anglais avec un professeur masqué on
est en train de compromettre leurs
études
qu'est-ce qu'elle plus gras notre santé
vieux ou l'éducation de nos enfants moi
je pense qu'elle a un passé aussi quand
même aux professionnels parce que vous
avez des gens depuis le mois de mars
leur activité est compromise on leur a
dit faites des terrasses vous allez
pouvoir accueillir les gens il paraît
que c'est un investissement qu'on fait
quand on fait les terrasses et une
semaine après on leur dit pas mais
finalement vous êtes vous ferme à 10
heures du soir
c'est quand même vraiment pour eux une
espèce de montagnes russes difficile à
vivre mais moi je voudrais juste réagir
sur ce que vous dites parce que
aujourd'hui on ferme pas marseille pour
les personnes âgées on faire marseille
pour les soignants c'est les soignants
qui veulent pas voir des vagues de
patients qu'ovide arrivée de leur
service et c'est eux qu'on tirait la
sonnette d'alarmé en disant il est hors
de question qu'on des programmes des
soins pour accueillir des patients
coville donc ça ne vient de personne
d'autre que les soignants c'est les
soignants qui ont mis la pression sur
leur gouvernement en disant on n'en veut
pas de vague au vide on ne vivra pas
vous les comprenez l'esprit non le
problème je les comprends parfaitement
mais cette reprise n'est pas ce qu'on a
vu en mars avril en mars avril et se
sont pris un mur
c'est à dire qu'il ya eu 100 patients
par jour qui arrivait en réanimation
c'est un choc
là le terme de guerre et des biens
choisis vous imaginez 100 personnes vous
mettez vous remplissiez 15 personnes à
votre service de réanimation et les
autres ils sont dans le couloir vous
pouvez pas les soigner vous les envoyer
par train dans les autres régions donc
c'est un choc et monumental donc là
quand ils voient des patients arrivent
en réanimation
ça n'a aucun rapport ce n'est pas un mur
mais c'est un syndrome post traumatique
de ce qui s'est passé lors de la
première vague et la fermeture à
marseille cellier des médecins qui ne
veulent pas qu'ils ne veulent pas
revivre ce qu'ils ont vécu là moi je
connais plein de gens des infirmières
des médecins que cela ici c'est vraiment
une peur c'est une peur créent la peur
de la saturation il n'existe pas
aujourd'hui il faut répondre
actuellement il faut pouvoir soigner
leurs tables acier et il vous dit en
gros mais je prenais les décisions qui
n'ont pas lieu d'être aujourd'hui
alors ça c'est en tout cas le reflet
d'un traumatisme précédent je passais
beaucoup plus spécialistes comme en
épidémiologie non je n'irai pas le
contredire
moi je ne peux pas le contredire en
revanche sur le plan politique on est
obligé de prendre des bonnes décisions
des décisions justement des décisions je
pense qu'aucune décision n'ait vraiment
bonne ça se saurait aujourd'hui elles
sont toutes extrêmement rare pas
difficile
sont extrêmement difficiles ils l'ont
mal quand même région oui mais justement
elles ont été injustement l'a rappelé et
notamment on n'a pas du tout envie de
déprogrammer des soins qui était prévu
car nous avons eu des personnes qui
pendant la période du confinement ou des
pertes de chance ne pas être soignés
correctement
quel que soit l'âge est là pour le coup
on ne veut pas qu'ils font des maladies
laissez pas seulement le coc vide ou le
monde comme c'était le cas pendant le
confinement général du pays on va
rejoindre eric diard eric diard député
des bouches du rhône quand vous entendez
ce qui ce qui se dit sur ce plateau et
eric diard comment comment vous
réagissez j'imagine que pour vous ces
décisions sont insupportables nous avons
été surpris parce que comment vous
expliquer il y a une une décision
brutale qui s'est faite sans
concertation avec le ministre de la
santé il n'a pas vu aucun élu et est
simplement une heure avant avance à sa
prise de parole
il a prévenu un élu de marseille et le
président de région ou et la
concertation en tout cas olivier verront
on va l'écouter tout à l'heure explique
consulter c'est pas forcément tomber
d'accord qu'est ce que vous lui répondez
mais consulter
c'est pas tombés d'accord mais il n'a
pas consulté justement il n'a pas
consulté un seul élu avant de prendre sa
décision
il nous a mis devant le fait accompli
alors que la rs vient de lire qui a une
heure reconnaître que le taux
d'incidence que le taux de positivité
sont en train de baisser et que la seule
crainte qu'ils ont c'est un taux
d'incidence qui est encore fort pour les
personnes âgées
quand vous expliquer avec d'autres élus
eric diard que paris assassine marseille
est-ce que c'est pas un discours
dangereux que vous tenez
est ce qu'il n'ya pas un rite de divorce
entre les territoires et l'état mais je
ne vous dirai jamais que paris assassine
marseille je n'ai pas parce que regarder
paris est en train de subir également un
c'est un peu plus léger mais
22h c'est terrible et à la pédagogie pas
la ville mais je parlais du gouvernement
à l'accès l'état mais le gouvernement
vous voyez c'est un conte briques sur le
compte de le regarder macro macron il
dit il faut écouter les territoires et
vous avez un gouvernement qui prend des
décisions sans écouter les territoires
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous allez
faire vous faites partie des élus qui
vont déposer un recours avec renaud
muselier c'est ça vous manifesterez
demain écoutez je n'ai pas pris ma
décision
renaud muselier a décidé de faire un
recours liberté devant devant cet arrêté
préfectoral
je pense que la décision est injuste et
je pense qu'elle aurait mérité d'être vu
en amont avec l'ensemble des élus es et
s à une décision responsable dernière
question comment vous allez gérer sur
place le ras-le-bol qui monte à
marseille
comment faire pour faire respecter ces
mesures aujourd'hui et e
je démens j'appelle pas la rébellion
j'appelle simplement simplement le
gouvernement à écouter les élus et à
revoir peut-être sa décision parce que
j'aurai préfet aurait préféré que que
monsieur vers en disent écoutez la
situation est comme ceux ci et si elle
s'aggrave nous pendant des décisions
drastiques dans une semaine mais ça n'a
pas été le cas
merci beaucoup merci eric diard d'avoir
été en duplex avec nous depuis marseille
george pau langevin vous avez à chaque
fois cv il faut bien préciser ce n'est
pas paris contre marseille c'est le
gouvernement contrôle et que j'ai lu le
coup non mais ça n'empêche que les élus
locaux aujourd'hui sont responsables de
faire appliquer des mesures qui sont
légitimes et qu'ils sont prêts à
protéger la population parce que
gouverne municipalité est aussi assez
curieuse de la manière dont ça s'est
passé comment ça s'est passé précise m
justement parce qu'apparemment la
concertation a été très insuffisante et
ça va un peu à l'encontre des mesures
qui étaient en train d'être mise en
place pour permettre à l'économie de
repartir permettre aux gens de vivre et
c'est vrai que nous savons que des
personnes et a forcément été consulté la
consulter les élus faisaient les élus
apparemment semble dire que le préfet
les appelle
consultés sur le sujet petit à petit ces
mesures ne soit plus active et les voilà
c'est ça parce que je pense qu'il faut
bien nous dit le problème majeur
ce sont les personnes âgées mais quand
on empêche les gens de faire la fête
dans les bars se sont pas les personnes
âgées qui s'y trouve le plus souvent par
conséquent on est en train de mettre une
sorte de boisseaux sur des jeunes ce
sont ceux qui peuvent et contaminé qui à
un moment donné n'en peuvent plus et ce
qu'on voit d'ores et déjà c'est que ce
qui ne se passe pas dans dix bars au vu
et su de tous ce passe à des soirées
privées se passe une fois le rideau
baissé et dont on va continuer à
développer d'étape et des comportements
d'évitement et ça sera aussi très
dangereux dans carrément moment donné il
faut qu'on se dise que à force de
vouloir appuyer que sur la tête des gens
eh bien ça marchera par table assez on
nous dit vivre avec le virus est
aujourd'hui à des mesures comprennent
très très dur qui tombe
est-ce que c'est compréhensible non mais
c'est une question de gestion mais je
pense que c'était pas nécessaire de
faire ça et je suis d'accord
qu'effectivement je pense que l'épidémie
est déjà en train d' infléchir un petit
peu à marseille après je pense qu'ils
auraient je sais pas mais je pense qu'on
aurait quand même pu absorber les
quelques patients de plus qui aurait eu
après juste réagir sur ce que vous dites
puisqu'on entend beaucoup c'est oui on
ferme les bars et les restaurants et des
salles de sport ça va être des soirées
privées ça n'a aucun rapport
l'accélération épidémique avec un bar
elle est due au brassage c'est le fait
qu'ils aient plein de gens qui viennent
de différents endroits qui peuvent se
contaminer dans un même endroit qu'en
fait une soirée privée vous inviter au
cinq copains la maison c'est un petit
groupe
oui mais lorsqu'à la voix sert ce cas
les immenses soirée ou mais les
invitations en open sur facebook
ils viennent de toute façon c'est l'aise
non pas lieu mais les petites soirées
entre amis n'ont rien à voir avec
l'ouverture d'un bar de nuit donc je
sais pas pareil dernière petite question
parce qu'on va avoir un petit sujet sur
l'a4 contamination ici même à
l'assemblée nationale sur la méthode
pour terminer on a compris que la crise
était pilotée dont les territoires et
que ces préfets qu'il prenait la main ça
c'était le discours de de castex tâches
ménagères
aujourd'hui c'est olivier ferrand qui
explique depuis paris ce qu'il faut
faire c'est compliqué de vous suivre
quand on prend l'exemple je prends
l'exemple de la ville de paris veut
corriger si je me trompe je crois que
dans les bars et restaurants il ya eu à
peu près je crois de
j'avais noté sa 300 mises en demeure 40
décision de fermeture
donc il ya bien une action locale une
décision locale qui a été prise pour
répondre à cette nécessité de proximité
moi je suis tout à fait en phase avec ça
et ça me semble très important d'être en
accord avec ce qui se passe et la
section locale
mais le cas aujourd'hui est-ce que je ne
peux pas me prononcer mais ce que la
diffusion de l'épidémie le nombre de cas
fait qu'à un moment ça dépasse les
capacités du local je ne suis pas
capable de le juger
je le regrette en tout cas c'est certain
que c'est plus facile mais à un moment
ait des décisions pointe qui je le
répète de toute façon il n'y a pas de
bonnes décisions il n'y a que des
décisions extrêmement compliqué allez on
va terminer facile mais si vous voulez
mon avis se prendre la peine de discuter
ensemble un certain temps avec l'âme la
muette paris
ça n'aurait pas été si compliqué que ça
on va terminer avec l'un des secrets les
mieux gardés de cette maison combien y
at-il de 4go vide à l'assemblée
nationale le le palais bourbon était
devenu rappelez-vous 1 kloster mister à
paris c'était en mars dernier c'était le
premier alors qu'en est il aujourd'hui
c'est thomas des prêts qui a mené l
enquête pour nous n'est ce pas thomas
oui exactement myriam l'épidémie
s'accélère en france est forcément les
députés ne sont pas épargnés je vous
raconte tout ça alors comme moi vous
avez écouté hier le ministre de la santé
olivier verrons nous dire que l'épidémie
reprend s'accélère c'est le cas ici
aussi à l'assemblée où de nouveaux
carrés apparaissent selon nos
informations il ya au moins cinq députés
qui ont été testés positifs au
coronavirus ces derniers jours c'est le
cas notamment de deux députés la
république en marche qu'ils auront du
public sur twitter chris coons et lyon
et stéphane texter et puis une troisième
mireille robert elle a été déclarée
positive la semaine dernière et a décidé
de se confiner dans son bureau à
l'assemblée nationale pendant sept jours
elle l'a d'ailleurs annoncé ce matin sur
rtl
elle était invitée de la matinale et
elle a raconté son quotidien confiné
écoutez je suis maintenant la reine des
pâtes à la bouilloire voilà moi ça me
rappelle ma chambre universitaire que
j'avais à toulouse quand j'étais
étudiante le quotidien le linge ça ça va
ça peut se laver dans un outil m6 lavabo
de deux salles de bains d'ailleurs je
les bouchers parce que je goûte aussi
n'est pas dedans et le schéma petite
vaisselle donc heureusement que j'avais
du déstockage et plus le début
et moi même bien sûr vous en doutez des
mesures ont été prises pour éviter les
contaminations au sein de l'assemblée
les masques sont obligatoires en
commission par exemple je rappelle avant
que vous devez garder vos masques et les
porter correctement donc biaisé pam
était pas sous le nez au dessus de la
tête
alors les députés à son masque et des
masques en tissu en papier made in
france
mais parfois les récalcitrants se font
rappeler à l'ordre excusez moi monsieur
de conscience je vais garder votre masse
on a bon dos mais est ce que vous
entendrez oui on vous entendra bonjour
la haine rossi alors vous vous êtes
questeur de l'assemblée nationale c'est
vous avec deux de vos collègues qui
gérait le bon fonctionnement de
l'institution on a vu le port du masque
est obligatoire en commission quels sont
les autres règles sanitaires qui
s'impose ici nous avons pris très tôt
des mesures assez strictes en matière de
gestes barrière le port du masque
obligatoire en commission mais aussi
dans l'hémicycle avant également fermé
l'assemblée à tout visiteur extérieur
pour justement éviter toute reprise de
la circulation du virus dans ses murs et
si l'épidémie venait à reprendre
beaucoup plus ici à l'assemblée que
l'assemblée devenait un cluster quelles
mesures seraient prises ici dans
l'ensemble de l'assemblée nationale nous
avons effectivement un scénario de repli
qui consisterait en cas de reprise grave
du virus au sein du palais bourbon je le
rappelle un 4000 personnes au delà des
députés travaillent ici
jour et nuit eh bien nous aurions à ce
moment là une solution de repli que nous
avions adopté par le passé qui
consisterait à limiter le nombre de
députés en commission et dans
l'hémicycle voilà myriam le dernier
décompte officiel connus datent de la
fin de semaine dernière à cette date
huit députés collaborateurs et
fonctionnaires avaient été testés
positifs
on ne connaît pas de nouveaux décomptes
officiels mais les services de
l'assemblée assure tout est fait pour
éviter de créer de nouvelles
contaminations et risquer d'être
paralysé pour les prochaines semaines
merci thomas hahn je ne sais pas de quoi
s'inquiéter cinq cas à l'assemblée
vigilance comme partout en tout 2 ji
quotidienne plusieurs cas par semaine
dans notre groupe parlementaire
voilà une vigilance est un choix
personnel de venir ou de ne pas venir
pour le moment l'assemblée doit
fonctionner et peut continuer à
fonctionner pour le coup et questions au
gouvernement les mystiques qui vient des
quatre coins de la france on est
effectivement est la question
on est effectivement assez nombreux todt
pour les questions au gouvernement mais
je pense que depuis le mois de mai
on travaille quand même des conditions
difficiles puisque nos collaborateurs
sur le plus souvent en télétravail ce
qui signifie que les députés doivent
continuer à faire leur dossier à était
revenu ir et par conséquent ils le font
souvent faut être aidé on a fermé des
permanences au public donc la petite
pareil c'est compliqué j'espère que ça
va pas durer encore trop longtemps parce
qu'on rentre vraiment un service qui est
détériorée à la population merci
beaucoup on va parler à présent de votre
livre et de l'amoureux de montaigne que
vous êtes petit nous aider à tirer un
peu de son philosophique de cette crise
sanitaire on voit cela tout de suite
bonne soirée jingle bells jingle a pas
de jingle alors monteil le voile
[Musique]
montaigne andré comte sponville
montaigne je le disais qu'ils occupent
une place immense dans votre travail
depuis toujours corps et il pensait
qu'aurait il pensé ce philosophe de ce
que nous traversons d'abord montaigne qu
pas seulement une place dans ma vie dans
mon travail c'est un immense écrivain le
plus grand écrivain français disait
andré gide qui s'y connaissent en
littérature moi je dirais l'un des deux
plus grands écrivains français avec
victor hugo mais ça dit assez quel est
le niveau où il se situe et par ailleurs
cet écrivain est aussi un grand
philosophe c'est quelqu'un qui inventent
notre modernité et d'oncle est important
de évidemment dans parleurs s'agissant
maintenant de la situation qu'est ce
qu'il dirait il dirait au fond la même
chose pour jean paul ii il ya quelques
décennies
n'ayez pas peur ou n'ayez pas peur à ce
point parce qu'il a vécu bien pire alors
on parle de violence aujourd'hui en
arrêtant de la condamnée mais lui il a
vécu les guerres de religion des
dizaines de milliers de morts 3000 morts
rien qu'à paris en 48 heures au moment
de la saint barthélemy 3000 protestants
massacrés en deux jours et puis on parle
de la coved 19 lui il a connu la peste y
compris à bordeaux taux de mentalité de
la paix ce proche de 100 % taux de
mortalité de la coved moins de 1 pour
savait dire m'a dit la paix c'est au
moins 100 fois plus grave que la copie
de 19
et pourtant il nous apprend à
l'affronter prudemment quand la paix est
arrivé il est parti bien sûr tu es la
seule façon de s'en protéger à l'époque
ça n'est pas un risque tout mais il nous
donne des leçons
de sérénité des leçons de sagesse ou sa
fille n'aura pas de ce que tu es malade
cette base là tu es tu d'accord
montaigne écrit dans les essais ce dont
j'ai le plus peur c'est la peur eh bien
je vais vous dire c'est la phrase qui
résume le mieux mon état d'esprit actuel
je n'ai pas peur du lac au visage me
protège encore une fois je fais pas
n'importe quoi mais j'ai peur de la peur
j'ai peur de ce climat d'angoissé qui
peuvent être l'arrêt lombez sur sur les
jeunes de notre pays
et s'il est serein en effet c'est que
lui il accepte d'être mortel et c'est la
phrase que vous évoquiez tu ne meurs pas
de ce que tu es malade tu meurs de ce
que tu es vivant
autrement dit la mort fait partie de la
vie et on ne peut pas aimer la vie si on
n'accepte pas d'être mortel nous parler
d'un pan médicales istm dangereux qu'est
ce que ça veut dire en plaisantant
parpaings medicalis c'est l'idée de tout
confier à la médecine autrement dit
c'est l'idéologie qui tend à faire de la
santé la valeur suprême et donc de
déléguer aux médecins la gestion non
seulement de nos maladies ce qui est
normal mais la gestion de nos vies et de
nos sociétés et voyez ce qui
m'inquiétait au moment du confinement
que j'ai respecté dont j'ai dit qu'il
fallait le respecter
mais ce qui m'a inquiété c'est que je me
suis demandé au fond qu'est ce que je
ferais à la place de macron il me suis
dit mais au fond j'aurais fait la même
chose
pas du tout parce que je pensais que le
confinement était la meilleure solution
la vérité je n'en savais rien mais parce
qu'il y avait une telle pression du
corps médical envoyé 15 médecins tous
les soirs au journal de 20 heures à la
télévision une telle pression médiatique
une telle inquiétude dans la population
fallait que si les mais on n'avait pas
confiné de rue un tel tollé que la
france devenait ingouvernable
et bien ça c'est inquiétant c'est à dire
que le politique n'a plus d'autonomie
parce qu'il est soumis aux dictats des
médecins et des médias et ça c'est un
mauvais coup pour la démocratie
j'aimerais vous soumettre un sujet sur
les personnes âgées et un dialogue avec
la journaliste nathalie lévy qui va nous
rejoindre
depuis le début de la crise le
gouvernement tâtonnent sur nos aînés
entre interdiction est simple
recommandation
le casse tête de l'exécutif face aux
seniors c'est signé elsa monde un gars
va regarder face à un virus qui
s'attaque en priorité aux plus de 65 ans
faire des personnes âgées les seniors
ceux d'un certain âge les vieux le
gouvernement a beaucoup hésité
simard ce dernier autant dire il ya une
éternité emmanuel macron se rend dans un
ehpad à paris sans masque à l'époque ce
n'est pas l'usagé
il appelle à limiter les visites aux
résidents le 12 mars la france n'est pas
encore peaufiner mais le président de la
république appelle toutes les personnes
âgées cette fois à s'isoler
je demande ce soir à toutes les
personnes âgées de plus de 70 ans de
rester autant que possible à leur
domicile
quatre jours plus tard le chef de l'état
annonce le confinement généralisée du
pays
françaises français nous sommes en
guerre les personnes âgées en ehpad déjà
interdite de visite sont ensuite
confinés dans leur chambre
une situation qui interpelle lui atteint
10,2 pouces sont emmanuel macron à
corriger la situation
madame votre peine nous bouleverse tous
pour vous pour tous nos aînés en maison
de retraite ou en établissement les
visites des proches sont désormais
autorisées puis vient le temps de penser
aux déconfinement mais là encore
l'elysée semble vouloir un traitement
différence nous demanderons aux
personnes les plus vulnérables aux
personnes âgées en situation de handicap
sévère aux personnes atteintes de
maladies chroniques de rester même après
le 11 mai
confiné tout au moins dans un premier
temps des confinés par tranche d'âge une
idée qui ne passe pas alors le premier
ministre choisit la recommandation
plutôt que l'obligation
il faut qu'ils respectent des règles
similaires à la période de confinement
il n'y aura pas de contrôle pour les
plus âgés d'entre nous mais je demande
aux personnes les plus âgées les plus
fragiles de la patience depuis sans
prendre de mesures spécifiques envers
les seniors le gouvernement les invite à
la plus grande prudence et à quelques
sacrifices
par exemple évitons que papy et mamie
aille chercher les enfants à l'école
andré comte sponville cette petite
phrase elle vous agace du premier le
plus grave il ya une maladresse dans
l'expression non ce qui me peine c'est
le sort des vieux en l'occurrence août
ma belle mère est morte pendant le
confinement dans l'ehpad où elle
résidait pas de la copie du morte
peut-être bien de vieillesse il avait 95
ans mais à cause du confinement
elle n'avait pas vu ses trois enfants
depuis cinq semaines lundi elle est
morte seule tragiquement seul quelqu'un
qui meurt à 95 ans est pas un scandale
était normal qu'elle meurt un jour 95
ans mais qu'elle meurt seul centre a vu
aucun de ses enfants pendant cinq
semaines c'est quand même une souffrance
considérables pourraient pour pour ses
enfants
encore une fois majolique sur le
confinement je les respecte et puisque
tu es une décision démocratique monsieur
bio au gouvernement et que vous ne peut
pas ne pas considérer soit la france là
qu'est venue avec le confinement on sent
bien on absolument d'être là j'avais
envie d'initier un dialogue entre vous
deux parce que vous êtes l'auteur de ce
livre absolument passionnant et plein de
tendresse ça s'appelle courage au coeur
et sac à dos et aux éditions du rocher
on vous connaît parce que vous avez vous
avez été l'un des visages de bfm tv vous
étiez à europe 1 jusqu'à la saison
dernière
et puis vous écrivez on découvre en fait
que vous avez une double vie d'une
certaine manière parce que tous les
matins vous êtes aux côtés de rosine
votre grand mère qui est presque
centenaire et avec votre mère et votre
temps que vous n'avez jamais voulu aux
fonds qu'elles aillent en ehpad
vous n'avez jamais voulu la sortir de
votre quotidien
au fond vous avez besoin d'elle autant
qu'elle a qu'elle a besoin de vous
d'abord comment comment cette période
qu'ovide s'est passé pour elle et pour
vous est-ce qu'elle a tout bouleversé ou
pas alors oui elle a tout bouleversé
parce que tout simplement la grand mère
a fait une chute le 13 mars
donc le lendemain de l'annoncé par
emmanuel macron du confinement
généraliser le lundi donc on était
vraiment trois jours avant elle a fait
une chute donc elle a été hospitalisée
en urgence
et puis du coup trois semaines de
séparation parce que
le confinement est très stricte à ce
moment là on est vraiment dans les
débuts et du coup voilà impossible de
lui parler ou quasiment on l'a par
téléphone mais très peu et c'est très
compliqué parce qu'effectivement elle
est très habitué à vivre avec nous dans
une forme de ronde à 3 qu'on a mise en
place depuis des années déjà de manière
très mécanique en fait papa
conscientiser on est là moi le matin ma
mère le soir ma tante l'après mid ali
est dense et dans tmh une petite fille
aimante et dante parce que maintenant
c'est comme ça qu'on effectivement qu'on
l'a officialisé mais je me considère pas
comme étant toujours est il qu
effectivement on a sept cette
organisation autour d'elle pour la
pérenniser chez elle dans ses meubles
dans ses photos dans dans son intérieur
parce qu on a toujours considéré que
tout ce qu'elle avait fait pour nous
cela dès mon premier souffle on ne
pouvait que lui rendre et comme je suis
sûr vous avez écouté le débat qui a
précédé comment on réagit c'est quand
vous entendez andré comte peuvent ils
dire finalement attention toutes les
morts ne se ne se valent pas forcément
on prend des décisions qui vont avoir
des conséquences terribles pour la
jeunesse au fond moi je peux dire ça
delage dont je parle est ce que ça vous
choque est ce que ça vous heurte alors
il ya deux choses en fait avec andré
comte solide parce qu'on est tout à fait
d'accord sur les libertés individuelles
et moi je pense qu'on est vraiment
responsabilités en conscience on peut
avancer savoir si les grands-parents
peuvent aller voir les petits enfants la
sortie des écoles je considère que oui
on nous a beaucoup peint stylisé on est
dans un paternalisme poussé à l'extrême
et c'est très grave parce
qu'effectivement l' isolement ça tu
certainement plus que le coc vide ça tue
beaucoup plus que le coc vide donc cette
bienveillance pousser comme ça à son
paroxysme c'est très grave
ça c'est le premier point le deuxième
point c'est que je pense qu'on peut pas
être dedans et on a déjà plein de
conflits sociétaux et se retrouver en
face de conflits générationnels opposait
deux générations les anciens ou les
vieux puisque allons-y d' appelons les
choses telles qu'elles sont à la
jeunesse c'est pas la solution il s'agit
pas de privilégier les anciens il
s'agissait simplement de les
responsabiliser l'ordre voilà vous
voulez tellement les vieux qu'est ce
qu'ils veulent ils veulent profiter du
temps qu'il leur reste avec leurs
proches
donc ils sont en capacité d'avoir
certainement pour savoir oui tu mets un
masque oui je rencontre la famille oui
je la vois mais surtout j'ai envie d'en
profiter au risque d'une guerre ne se
valent pas c'est un constat presque
d'évidence il est plus triste de mourir
à 20 ou 30 ans que de mourir à 68 ans
mon âge ou à 81 ans l'âge moyen des
décès de la cofidis ça ne se discute
même pas tout le monde sait que pour un
adulte
perdre un enfant c'est plus douloureux
que perdre un set
c'est pas important ça veut dire que
c'est moins du moins dramatique que la
mort qu'il faut - le morcellement de la
rose n ya pas de conflit des générations
c'est une race c'est une expression qui
existait dans ma jeunesse qui a
totalement disparu du discours
journalistique et pour cause c'est que
les jeunes sont très respectueux très
aisément de leurs parents à fond pour la
famille a toujours dit non non il n'y a
pas de compte les générations on est en
train de sacrifier une génération
la jeunesse est comme n'y a pas de
conflit ils ont la gentillesse de la
mode et de la craie tandis qu'un autre
est mort ça veut dire ça me donne ça
veut dire le pleurer ça veut dire que le
chemin est difficile mais c'est mais
c'est comparable à la mort de nos aînés
qu'est-ce que plus graves ceux de trois
cent mille jeunes qui arrivent au
chômage ou quelqu'un qui meurt que ma
belle-mère à 95 ans ou à 81 ans l'âge
moyen du coc vide il rien me des remous
j'ai reçu des dizaines de messages de
félicitations
la plupart venant de gens ayant mon à
jouer temps pluvieux qui me disent
médiation vous avez raison ce qui compte
pour nous c'est l'avenir nos deux petits
enfants c'est pas ma petite santé moi je
peux me cloîtré chez moi c'est je me
protéger mais l'idée que je demande à
mes gars sont des trentenaires de ne pas
sortir pour protéger la santé de leurs
vieux t'as pas alors ça ça me paraît
totalement fou il a profité de la vie
soyez prudent pour vous mais ne vous
inquiétez pas pour ma santé à moi ma
santé je m'en charge at elle est là où
on se rejoint en définitive parce que
très clairement cette cette prise de
conscience et ce besoin qu'ont les aînés
d'être entourés de leurs proches
ce que c'est une bande besoin c'est une
nécessité c'est intrinsèque c'est
épidermique c'est tout ce que vous
voulez donc il ya cette nécessité
après il ya peut-être eu des raccourcis
et dans la manière que vous avez eu deux
de dire les choses où on a beaucoup
entendu aussi emmanuel todd ou françois
de closets dire voilà on sacrifie les
jeunes le problème c'est que si on avait
fait si on avait dit la même chose
s'agissant de la couleur de peau
ça s'appelle ni plus ni moins que de
l'apartheid
donc on est aussi dans la limite un peu
de l'exercice et dans la limite de la
formulation on peut pas on peut pas
sacrifier les vieux lawson a parlé de
sacrifier les vieux voilà mais c'est
typiquement le politiquement correct ou
plutôt le sanitairement correct en
l'occurrence l'idée qu'on n'ait pas le
droit de dire que c'est plus triste de
mourir à 20 ans qu'à 81 ans
c'est quand même inuit monde et ont créé
vieux le disait tous les vieux c'est
bien mais c'est pour ça que je veux dire
on va à défaut au sauveur de mourir
c'est la nouvelle voulue mais nous
apprend à accepter d'être mortel et
c'est là peut-être la phrase la plus
importante a cité aujourd'hui montaigne
écrit dans les essais je veux qu'on
agisse et qu'on prolonge les offices de
la vie tant qu'on peut on viendra le
plan de l'immortalité et que la mort et
que la mort me trouve plantant meshoe
mais nonchalant d'elles est encore plus
de mon jardin un parfait et bien voilà
je souhaite vivre le plus longtemps
possible mais je n'ai pas peur de la
mort j'accepte nonchalamment d'être
mortel et je refuse de sacrifier mes
enfants à mon éventuel peur de la mort
on est en train de sacrifier l'amour de
la vie à la peur de la mort ça c'est un
contresens complet sur l'existence
humaine
je suis assez d'accord avec vous je
pense qu'il ya une vraie problématique
pour le gouvernement aujourd'hui nos
politiques savent plus gérer cette
question en fait cette question des
aînés d'ailleurs les aînés qu'est ce que
ça veut dire
les anciens les seniors + plus le
quatrième âge on est en train d'en
velopper tout ça dans jette dans des
jolies formules or simone de beauvoir
elle le disait très bien déjà il ya
cinquante ans on la vieillesse en fait
on a honte de nos vieux on est en train
de les dissimuler c'est moche ça pue
c'est pas joli à voir les corps abîmés
cetera on était déjà dans cette formule
qu'elle qu'elle nommait la conspiration
du silence
aujourd'hui c'est un peu pareil c'est
encore une fois poussée à son paroxysme
on les enferme dans des mouroirs dans
des établissements pour certains qu'ils
ont formidable avec un personnel
formidable ces ehpad mais ces ehpad qui
sont hors la ville
or la cité or ces vieux ils ont besoin
d'être dans la cité dans le monde dans
la société avec ça tape terre
générationnel 1
enfin obligatoire à mon sens il faut
revenir à ça donc je pense qu'on est
dans une surprotection qui fait du mal à
tout le monde et qui économiquement
évidemment nous coûte beaucoup mais qui
aussi sur le plan de la considération
on sur le plan de la la couleur de notre
société fait énormément de mal on a
peut-être commis des erreurs il ya eu
des situations dans les ehpad ou les
personnes âgées étaient même enfermés
dans leur chambre pour ne pas rencontrer
de potentiels nouveaux nouveaux cas où
il va miner d'autres mais en même temps
on a beaucoup dit que pour la première
fois on avait choisi la vie sur
l'économie qu'on n'aurait pas pu
supporter d'une certaine façon de
collectivement de se regarder en face si
on n'avait pas confiner le pays
ce sont des choix moraux des choix
éthiques profond est qu'il faut pas s'en
féliciter andré comte sacrifier
l'économie à la vie ça aurait du sens
s'il y avait de la vie sans économie
sauf que sans économie on her est
beaucoup plus vite que de la copie digne
parce qu'on meurt de faim si vous voulez
et et donc il faut rappeler vos idées
que j'avais dit qu'il des choses plus
graves que la copie 19 oui il ya neuf
millions de personnes du maine qui
meurent chaque année de fin de
malnutrition 9 millions dont 3 millions
d'enfants meurent chaque année de
malnutrition entre ses parents
pourquoi est il meurt il meurt pour des
raisons économiques autrement dit la
misère plus plus vite que la maladie
quand je lui s'inquiéter pour l'économie
moment de 2 du confinement
c'était pas pour protéger les
milliardaires du cac 40 je m'en fous je
fais pas partie c'était pour protéger
les plus pauvres c'est tour des plus
pauvres qui souffrent de la crise
économique
pensez aux jeunes chômeurs aujourd'hui
qu'ils n'arrivent pas à trouver du
boulot pensez aux étudiants qui
terminent leurs études c'est quand même
plus inquiétant que le sort du cac 40 et
bien ça c'est l'économie
l'aïe a pas de vie sans économie et donc
prétendre sacrifier l'économie à la vis
et se racontent les escales et d'andré
comte-sponville est ce que vous vous
êtes pas comment vous observez
aujourd'hui la réaction du gouvernement
nos politiques sur le cas des seniors
parce que en 2060 un tiers de la
population aura plus de 60 ans là c'est
factuel ça nous arrive
l'asie a déjà de l'avancé sur nous et
ils sont ils sont d'ailleurs plutôt bien
réactif puisqu'ils sont précurseurs avec
des établissements qui mélangent et pas
des maternelles ou crèches
au rez-de-chaussée les pays bas le
danemark la suède aussi où nous les
vieux sont les plus heureux du monde
puisque ils sont considérés est-ce que
le problème il n'est pas là il n'est pas
plus large est ce que le gouvernement a
pas des difficultés et même les goûts
ornements successifs avec avec les plus
de 70 tout simplement
oui on a des problèmes avec les vieux
parce que vous avez raison c'est c'est
difficile à affronter au quotidien c'est
difficile à gérer politiquement donc
tout cela bien sûr est vrai mais
rappelons par exemple qui lie à chaque
année 225 mille nouveaux cas de la
maladie d'alzheimer 225 mille nouveaux
cas chaque année rien qu'en france taux
de guérison d'alzheimer 0% taux de
guérison de la cobi 19 99,5 % et on ne
parle que de la covin 19 et plus
personne le problème de la dépendance
à terme ce sera un problème beaucoup
plus grave que l'aco vibrer lagardère et
notamment de cette espèce de
polarisation médiatique et politique où
les gens n'ont plus que l'aco vide à la
bouche comme si tu étais le principal
intéressé
qu'est ce qu'on ferait qu'est ce qu'on
fait de nos vieux dans cette période de
deuxième vague de l'aco vide a le mieux
quand on peut les garder avec soi je
vous admire mais j'en ai besoin n'est
pas eu le courage ou pas les moyens on
pourrait épiloguer à l'infini mais c'est
vrai que ce qui se passe dans les ehpad
et d'une tristesse infinie
moi j'ai passé pas mal de temps et pour
mon père et pour ma belle-mère dans les
ehpad
sincèrement je préfère attrapé lakovic
19 et même je vous dis je préfère en
mourir que passé 10 ans en état de
dépendance que ce soit dans un ehpad ou
un service de gérontologie d'un grand
hôpital parisien comme la pompe est
entouré en tous les cas il n'est pas
question blaco vivent dans votre livre à
il en est tout petit peu question
puisqu'il est question d'aller à ce
moment là que vous chérissez et ça
s'appelle courage au coeur et sac au dos
prendre soin de ses aînés quelque chose
me dit que d'une certaine manière vous
allez faire un peu de politique pour
faire avancer les choses dans les mois
qui viennent sa part d'un témoignage
mais ça pourrait aboutir sur peut-être
une proposition de loi projet de loi ici
à l'assemblée on verra on est loin de ça
mais bon merci à leur parler le sujet
des aidants est une des préoccupations
de l'exécutif merci beaucoup
andré comte sponville vous restez avec
nous fait la dernière partie de cette
émission on va parler d'un sujet j'en
suis sûre qui vous tient à coeur la
recherche le projet de loi en discussion
à l'assemblée nationale divise alors que
pourtant les crédits augmentent pour
quelles raisons les réponses tout de
suite dans notre face à face
[Musique]
voilà 25 milliards d'euros sur dix ans
un investissement inédit pour le
gouvernement est pourtant un projet de
loi en trompe l'oeil pour les chercheurs
alors avant d'accueillir nos invités les
trois clés pour comprendre ce texte avec
marion le faire quel est le budget
actuel de la recherche 15 milliards
d'euros soit 2,2 pour cent du produit
intérieur brut
c'est loin des 3% promis en l'an 2000 et
des presque 4% de la corée du sud et du
japon
ce projet de loi de programmation de la
recherche prévoit d'injecter 25
milliards d'euros en 10 ans en
différentes étapes pour atteindre un
budget de 20 milliards d'euros en 2030
comment sont financés les laboratoires
de recherche
chaque laboratoire reçoit des crédits
régulier il s'agit de la dotation de
base calculée au prorata du nombre de
chercheurs
le laboratoire reçoit également les
crédits de l' agence nationale de
recherche
la nr sélectionne puis finance les
projets de chercheurs et elle donne 20%
de plus aux laboratoires qui accueille
le chercheur c'est ce qu'on appelle le
préciput il devrait atteindre 40 %
combien gagne un chercheur à l'issue
d'un doctorat un jeune chercheur touche
aujourd'hui 2500 euros brut par mois
soit en moyenne près d'un smic et demi
pour enrayer la fuite des cerveaux vers
l'étranger le projet de loi prévoit une
augmentation de salaire de 700 euros
soit 3200 euros cela reste encore
beaucoup moins que les 4200 euros gagnés
en moyenne par les jeunes chercheurs
dans les pays anglo saxons bonsoir
d'année les reins bonjour madame merci
d'être là vous êtes député la république
en marche de l'aude et vous êtes le
rapporteur de ce projet de loi dans
l'hémicycle et via skype normalement
isabelle this saint jean est avec nous
bonsoir vous êtes secrétaire national du
parti socialiste chargé des études et
spécialiste des questions liées à la
recherche et à l'enseignement supérieur
aux foules 25 milliards d'euros
madame le rapporteur c'est énorme on se
dit c'est inédit 25 milliards d'euros
sur dix ans en quoi ce texte va nous
permettre de nous remettre dans la
compétition internationale
en quoi ce texte va faire en sorte de
rendre plus attractif cette profession
de chercheurs si mal payés aujourd'hui
exactement je crois que vous mettez le
point sur les principaux bondir les
principales difficultés aujourd'hui que
l'on a dans les laboratoires de
recherche les chercheurs mais toutes les
équipes de chercheurs
c'est l'attractivité le manque
d'attractivité ça depuis vingt ans
peut-être au-delà même de 20 ans on n'a
jamais abordé le problème uniquement par
la partie budgétaire par la partie
salariale et parler la stabilisation des
emplois combien gagne un jeune chercheur
en moyenne 1 sciences dures sciences
humaines cantine quand ils arrivent
maître de conférences qui fait qu'ils
qui dit au post doctorat combien combien
on gagne en moyenne
disons s'il à 2000 euros net si c'est
pas mal déjà 2000 euros net et il rentre
à 34 ans c'est à dire que en tant que
chargé de recherche ou ou maître de
conférences ci démarre en moyenne à 34
ans et il devient professeur en moyenne
à 45 en 2000 euros net alors qu'est ce
que vous allez faire précisément déjà
augmenter ses salaires
déjà il ya l'augmentation des salaires
qui veut qui va arriver en effet on va
essayer de rue
lire aussi tout ce qui est précarité
c'est à dire que actuellement jeu comme
je vous disais vous vous rentrez au
premier grade si on peut dire c'est à
dire maître de conférences ou chargé de
recherche à 34 ans on va essayer de
baisser ceux ci pour des personnes en
effet qu'ils partent actuellement
l'étranger parce que ils peuvent se
faire embaucher de manière définitive
mieux la fuite des cerveaux isabelle
this saint jean sur cette question de la
rémunération de la valorisation des
carrières 25 milliards d'euros sur dix
ans 25% de thèses financées en plus 5200
créations de postes c'est pas rien non
alors il faut déconstruire tout ça
malheureusement il faut déconstruire
tout ça j'aimerais beaucoup que ça soit
vrai mais quand on regarde donc on a des
promesses de ses 25 milliards da de dos
en fait il faut déjà voir que c'est sur
dix ans jamais aucune loi de
programmation n'a été sur 10 ans tout le
monde le fait sur sept ans en général
donc déjà premiers éléments un peu
curieux deuxième élément quand on
regarde la manière dont le financement
iny c'est très curieux hier que les
premières années il n'y a pas beaucoup
de milliards qui tombe ça commence à
augmenter
donc on est quand même tard dans le
bilan du quinquennat on arrive
lyon s'il avait voulu y avoir un
investissements antérieurs ça aurait pu
être fait avant mais pas le son
imaginons que le gouvernement veille de
faire maintenant
et là qu'est ce qu'on constate c'est que
il n'ya aucune progression réelle dans
les années où le gouvernement est en
responsabilité là les sommes qui arrive
arrive à la fin de l'échéance vous
regardez la progression s'est érodée bus
et les voilà des centaines de millions
et puis à la fin effectivement on arrive
à des choses plus importantes
deuxième chose compliquée troisième
élément quand même complètement
invraisemblable et toute l'opposition
droite et gauche prg convenu a essayé de
le faire dit
la ministre jusqu'au moment où elle l'a
ni par erreur là ça commence à tourner
dans les réseaux parce que elle l'a
reconnu elle-même on dit 25 milliards
supplémentaires donc tout le monde se
dit ok chouette ça veut dire que à la
fin on va arriver un budget ou au lieu
d'avoir à peu près les 20 milliards
qu'on a aujourd'hui alors le périmètre
est compliqué ça on va avoir 40 5
milliards c'est ça qu'on se dit tous et
ben non
la réalité c'est qu'on va avoir cinq
milliards et dernier élément si vous me
permettez rapidement se montrer que
voilà on n'est pas du tout dans cet
échec on attend qui est absolument
indispensable qui nous permettrait
d'atteindre l'objectif des 1 % que
l'allemagne a atteint depuis un moment
un qui fait que nous on décroche
contrairement à d'autres pays qu'on
n'est plus on ne va plus être une grande
nation scientifiques et bien qu'est-ce
que qu'est ce qu'on constate d'abord on
constate que la modalité de financement
la ministre a pas répondu mais ça risque
d'être bien un tour de passe passe
autour des retraites
de l'argent qui va être récupérée par
l'état via les retraites on n'est pas du
tout sûr qu'il ya un investissement
c'est clair c'est très clair en fait
vous dénoncer un projet de loi en
trompe-l'oeil répondait point par point
parce que c'est vrai que s'engager sur
dix ans quand on est encore moins de
deux ans aux affaires
on peut douter de l'effectivité de ces
crédits déjà qu'est ce qui nous garantit
que les 25 milliards sur 10 ans seront
bien pour la recherche pour l'université
pour les labos alors en effet tout
d'abord disant pourquoi parce que c'est
le temps long de leurs recherches
la plupart des projets même les projets
des précédentes leur enseignement
supérieur les labex etc
c'était dans les dix ans environ dès la
première année en effet en mai 4 5
millions d'euros millions d'euros en
plus et chaque année ce montant va
progressivement les jusqu'à +6 5
millions d'euros et vous avez raison et
moi je n'ai jamais dit je pense qu'à me
soit jamais 10 25 milliards
supplémentaires
vous avez raison c'est simplement
chaque année on augmente la dotation qui
vaille à la fête je vais faire
départager ce bref échange et je m'en
excuse parce que voilà le temps qui nous
est imparti et est terminée andré comte
promis de vous êtes vous avez été
enseignant professeur de philo de pub
pendant des années vous savez très bien
qu'un chercheur qu un thésard c'est
difficile il peut valoriser vous fait
confiance à ce gouvernement pour
augmenter ses crédits ça va changer
il ya plus à plaindre que les chercheurs
ou enseignants d'université d'une part
d'autre part je suis pas compétent pour
juger du projet de loi que j'ai regardé
deux de trop loin dans ce qui me frappe
c'est la comparaison avec l'allemagne
il se trouve que l'allemagne depuis des
années est un pays plus riche que la
france et c'est plus facile d'avoir une
grande recherche dans un pays riche que
dans un pays pauvre
une façon de rappeler que ceux qui
veulent sacrifier l'économie à la santé
ont du souci à se faire parce que la
santé coûte cher on ne peut pas
augmenter les dépenses de santé en
nuisant perpétuellement à l'économie et
donc il faut arriver à penser les deux
ensemble la santé c'est très important
l'économie c'est très important aussi
mais tout sacrifier à la santé c'est un
contresens sur l'existant et vous l'avez
dit amplement voici le louvre âge que
vous signez aux éditions plon
dictionnaire amoureux de montaigne on
peut piocher évidemment à chaque lettre
pour mieux comprendre ce philosophe
merci mesdames ra merci mesdames
this-saint-jean être d'avoir été parfait
via skype en direct avec nous on
accordera un peu plus de temps à ce
projet doit recherche dans d'autres
émissions très belle soirée sur lcp et à
demain
[Musique]